in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Scott
and Becky are with us hey guys how are
you hi Dave hey Dave how's it going
Merry Christmas Merry Christmas to you
welcome where do you all live Mattoon
Illinois small town there east central
Illinois okay cool welcome to Nashville
good to have you so you're here to do it
that free scream we are yeah love it and
how much have you guys paid off well it
was about three hundred and forty five
thousand dollars Wow yeah that's house
our land which is our recreational
ground that we have 100% debt-free Dave
Wow took very little took three years
yep all right and your range of income
during that time um kind of in the 150
did little over 200 range very cool what
do you guys do for a living I'm in sales
mhm and I'm an accountant okay fun fun
so three hundred forty five thousand
that's the property the house everything
how much land have you got it's a little
shy of 80 acres okay very nice nice
piece of ground good and so what is all
of this real estate worth our house is
probably in the 250 range the land we
actually bought it for at an auction
about six years ago it's probably about
400 okay Wow so six hundred thousand
dollars worth of real estate all paid
for correct I'm looking at where people
that's right I love it I love it I love
it congratulations you guys thank you
very so tell me how this all started
what happened thirty six months ago got
you on this track well it's it actually
starts a little bit before that so we
got married in 2000 going to school
getting everything done and basically we
wanted to cash flow cash flow College I
wanted to get to that point so basically
starting a family I wanted to be able to
get to that point to where we had it
done buckle down worked full-time
graduated school both of us debt-free
Wow
moved into that immediately into my job
where I'm still still residing and Becky
was in a business opportunity as well
built a house in 2004 about two hundred
thousand dollars total and that had only
had a hundred thousand dollar debt on it
so paid that off in three years
okay so 2007 was debt-free but
and still reading your book and
everything else and doing all that stuff
abiding by the principles but 2010 the
land came up for sale and we're like you
know it's it we can get this done in
about probably seven to ten years mm-hmm
I don't think Dave would scream too bad
but but we're still going back into debt
but we think we can get it done and then
then as you say when you bring in debt
you bring in Murphy you bring in these
other things that are out there and even
though we were debt free making a great
income there was a job loss in 2012 okay
and so Becky was facing that and we
basically buckled down but at the same
time another opportunity presented
itself and that's where we got dumb so
so not only did we have the the land
debt but we basically had another
opportunity with the franchise and a
partnership to go into and we mortgaged
that land to go into business oh yeah
yeah it was it was a profitable business
it was but basically and I'll never
forget it
we're at the desire for crack we're at
the bank and if you know you talk about
those like Eureka moments or those
moments that are out there and what
should have been the trigger was when I
looked at Becky and she had a tear
rolling down her face saying should we
do this and I and and my head was saying
you're you know it's one plus 1 does not
equal 3 but my heart and some of the
opportunities that were out there that I
felt was there i justified it and when
we both justified it together and so we
signed we did it and about a year later
we really came to that conclusion that
holy cow how dumb were we in making that
decision but now we're into 2013 and
essentially at that point we knew that
we had to buckle down and get this stuff
squared away so when we bought in we had
that opportunity and it's a franchise so
there's there some there's some assets
there but but we also we also got into
that from the standpoint of the the debt
load that was there too so the 365 or
345 was really just us from a standpoint
of that but basically at that point said
hey we got to do something
and again just buckle down I work more
got up earlier stayed up later because
you should till have the business or you
sell it
that so basically in 2015 we came back
and said listen for us to really grow
this business to where it needs to be
and with our partner we were going to
have to buy him out eventually we're
looking at millions of dollars in debt
and at that point we said this is not
who we are
we knew we weren't that person in 2013
when we signed the loan we don't want to
continue to be those people
so basically 2015 we came back in there
and Becky and I had a really you know
good heart-to-heart do we really
wouldn't really want to do this at 36
years old now and 33 34 years all the
time do we really want to do that
another ten years from now and be 50 55
years old and finally have everything
paid off the answer was no it was it was
unequivocal though
and so Lord willing we were able to get
it all squared away and in May of 2016
sold the last part of the business and
with that last bit we paid off her house
all right back at back deck spray again
there was a good time yeah and and a new
a new resolution in your house yes never
again never right it wasn't as fun
really really it wasn't well and I had
the luxury Dave of doing my my regular
job in sales and Becky was the one that
was dealing with the business so when
you talk about you know something that
broke and then all of a sudden that draw
that you were kind of depending upon to
pay the mortgage or to pay those bills
it didn't it wasn't there now here and
so the entrepreneurial spirit is still
there we love that idea
was it the business self or enough to
pay this off in one fell swoop then oh
no okay so you've been given beating on
it we had the final the final straw was
the business selling okay well
congratulations you guys Wow mom sorry
you went through all this I'm glad
you're out how's it feel now to be free
I would say you know just light and not
stress because like I said we both
always lived by you know your rules of
you know we never had a car alone we
never bought anything that we couldn't
go pick cash for beside our house so
when we did that I know when you did
stupid you did it babe we did
we did and I think the minute we did we
both just felt this weight on us and so
for those few years it took us a while
to really like come to that and tell
each other you know we were both like oh
it was a good choice if it's good choice
and then one day we were just both like
yeah you know I feel like I'm drowning
do you feel the same way and he's like
yeah so we then started knocking away at
the debt in the meantime while we got
the businesses where they needed to be
so that we could sell them and get that
last piece of the puzzle good for you
well done good job guys and it's amazing
when you have that wait I will say as a
sales guys when he sales guys that are
out there I'm telling you it'll it'll
give you a goal and and now it's it's
amazing that I had my record years the
last three years
mm-hmm so don't be set for that so now I
don't have the debt but I like the money
so different motivations ain't pain and
pleasure principle right all right and
your kids names and ages
Madison is 16 and Brock is 11 all right
very cool 345 oh we got a copy of Chris
Hogan's for I do that we gotta look for
you the the retire inspired book number
one bestseller and that's the next
chapter in your all's lives and you're
going to be easily calling back very
soon with a millionaire status if you're
not already there I think we are so all
right three hundred and forty five
thousand dollars paid off in thirty six
months making 100 to 200 or 150 to 200
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream all right three two one we're
free
well done you guys great work hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
[Music]
Oh